now the metropolitan police has been
defending its handling of the euro 2020
final and says its intervention
prevented a further escalation of
violence
the football association has launched a
review into what it's calling
unprecedented levels of public disorder
which could see england fans banned from
future games
but should there be further action
joining me now is julian knight he's the
chair
of the digital culture media and sport
select
committee who's been writing to the fa
today
thanks for being with us some of the
stories that are emerging on social
media and have been over the last
couple of days certainly in messages
i've been getting from people who
were there it does seem the scale and
the toxic nature of what happened there
was worse than thought as were the
security failures
yeah i think it was appalling and
shaming
the truth of the matter is that i mean i
was getting texts
on the night about what was happening
and from volunteers
and i think there was it's been a
cataclysmic failing
of security around the ground
uh even against normal standards but
it's even made more acute
as we're going through a global pandemic
and you would think that in such a
situation that there would be
halt points along the way to wembley and
that frankly there will be much better
organization
and and stewarding of those who are
trying to
uh get into the into the ground right so
so what do you think
yeah yeah so what are the specific
questions you want answered by the fa
well we'd like to know how many people
got into the ground um
ticketless uh a good estimate that we're
hearing
could be up to five thousand uh
extraordinary numbers we want to find
out as well
why it is that no lessons were learned
from the champions league final in
when several hundred manchester united
supporters and barcelona supporters
broke in in similar but in a less
dramatic fashion
and also we'd like to see precisely what
security was in place
uh what conversations we have with the
police what covert security was in
police and why was it
that people were allowed to get right up
to the stadium without having their
tickets properly checked i've been to
quite a few of these events as we've
started i was in wimbledon that day
and in all of them there was these halt
points on the way to the stadium
and that doesn't seem to have happened
this time i mean uefa
are also investigating but where do you
think responsibility lies the fas seem
to be saying they were responsible for
inside the stadium and they say
it was the police outside where where do
you think responsibility lies
i mean obviously clearly i've got to say
clearly everything
to get right no well clearly
responsibility lies with
those guys get forcing their way into
wembley that's the first thing to say
yeah and absolutely i
certainly have some see those who have
been posting on social media going to
knock at the door from the police
uh forth with but yeah they actually
have three things to get right in this
country just the grassroots football
the england team itself and wembley
stadium
and i'm afraid they have failed on that
final point
and the not me gov type approach that
they initially took
once this story emerged is just not good
enough you know there were 30 police
officers
that were injured on this occasion so
i'm not going to investigate the police
in any way
but what i would say very simply when it
comes to the fa
they had this happen before they should
have learned the lessons
they should know that this would be a
hugely in-demand game
and frankly this has a huge impact in
terms of our world cupboard
and in terms of our relationship with
uefa well i was going to ask you about
that i mean
this trouble coupled with the racism
issue where does that leave the bid
for 2030. yeah and also the booming
national anthems which i think is
i think any normal burst would say was
not funny at all and pretty pretty
shameful actually
i think it's i hate to say dead in the
water
but i was not optimistic beforehand
because frankly we don't have a good
reputation within the wider football
community
and also we i do wonder whether or not
fifa is thoroughly reformed
but uefa and we need the backing of uaf
in order to
enter the world cup competition they
have the opportunity to spain
or portugal or ourselves
and frankly after this performance i
think it's much more likely they'll go
for spain and portugal
rather than us right so you say any
possible world cup bid
is effectively dead in the water um and
would you suggest that the fa or the
government
just didn't bid now i think that
the process uh is expensive
and we were humiliated last time i think
we were the only country that voted for
ourselves
and i really do hope that there is real
thought exactly what we actually do
in terms of the world cupboard one other
thing i'd like to mention though mark
is it is more than frankly world cups
and that sort of thing
this is actually about safety i was
listening to some of the stories coming
out of this the crush things like that
it was awfully reminiscent of it
hillsborough
and i rock stadium disasters and we
cannot have that happen
again in this country we just cannot so
what we've got to do first of all
before we think about any world cup bids
is sort this out and know exactly what
went wrong
and ensure that something like this
never happens again isn't the great
shame that we've
got a team and a manager who have
done so much to you know he's produced a
diverse
socially aware team that's done very
well
and then we're saying well let's not bid
for 2020 uh 2030 because
you know the fans are going to ruin it
and the racists are going to ruin it
well i wouldn't put it quite like what
i'd say first of all is yet
gareth southgate
has been a fantastic example to us all i
mean you know the way he talks
is he's really inspiring he can see it
in his young team
absolutely brilliant and really proud of
what they've done
so many mindless idiots and it's it's a
it seems to be a couple of hours a few
thousand miles lose
i've ruined a lot for a lot of people a
lot of people's fun and that is
is wrong in itself it doesn't mean that
frankly we need to literally wear a hair
shirt and never actually even consider
a bid going forwards but we do need to
understand where we sit
in the football hierarchy globally and
not kid ourselves we're not liked
by the the the majority of football
nations
for historic reasons for many reasons
and then basically what we have done to
those who say
that we should be we shouldn't actually
have a world cup but is give them
uh ammunition if you like because the
one thing we always could say to them
was
okay we have the stadiums we can run it
and
unfortunately that unique selling point
doesn't look
much of a selling point any longer no it
doesn't it's all pretty depressing
uh julian knight thanks very much
appreciate your time